le premier des freins malheureusement il
reste économique c'est à dire que on
peut tout demander aux agriculteurs ils
sont tous de bonne volonté pour pour
produire mieux et pour produire plus
sain pour produire plus plus vers le
seul problème c'est qu'il faut qu'il y
ait une rémunération derrière les
salaires c'est là où le bât blesse
généralement c'est que voilà on demande
plus mais sans forcément ramené de
valeur ajoutée pour l'agriculteur et
c'est là le gros problème quoi quelle
est la mesure dans la future pac qui
pourrait justement vous apporter une
sécurité financière pour des mesures y
en a beaucoup après
la sécurité financière je suis pas
certain que la pac soit le seul outil
pour pour permettre aux agriculteurs de
se sortir de l'impasse dans laquelle ils
sont il ya toute une stratégie autour de
la structuration de filières avec
notamment le débat autour des états
généraux de l'alimentation qui a eu lieu
il ya quelques il ya quelques mois
voilà c'est un ensemble la pac est un
outil qui permet aux agriculteurs de
d'essayer de vivre de leur métier
mais cet outil n'est pas viable si les
filières ne se structure pas comment
vous à titre personnel vous revoyez
l'agriculture dans 10 ans ou votre
métier à vous dans dix ans je pars du
principe que les agriculteurs sont
capables de s'adapter à beaucoup de
choses
on en a vu l'exemple depuis depuis des
décennies voilà chacun sait
l'agriculture a beaucoup évolué et je
pense là maintenant que l'agriculture
l'avenir de l'agriculture n'est plus
entre les mains des agriculteurs ou plus
seulement entre leurs mains elle est
aussi entre les mains des consommateurs
l'acte de consommation et l'acte d'achat
et pour nous aujourd'hui une valeur
fondamentale
les consommateurs français doivent
prendre leurs responsabilités et se
poser les bonnes questions à savoir est
ce qu'on souhaite conserver une
agriculture durable dans notre pays et
dans ce cas-là consommer les produits de
notre pays ou bien continuer de
consommer au moins cher des produits qui
viennent de l'autre bout du monde et qui
sont complètement complètement
nocifs pour la santé donc voilà je pense
que l'une des réponses
elle est dans l allée chez le
consommateur